[Música]
cuando cuando yo era una criaturita
pequeño infante
le pedí a santo un xbox quiero que
imaginen a un niño lleno de ilusiones de
sueños esperanzas pidiéndole a santa el
regalo de sus sueños
ese niño era yo
y tenía 17 años pero básicamente lo
mismo entonces
pues yo le pedí un xbox a santa el día
llega navidad bajo el árbol veo el
regalo lo veo un poco más chico de lo
que yo me imaginaba
ya estés antes bien promise está seguro
lo sacó de su caja para despistar me
cuando agarró el regalo me doy cuenta
que está muy suave ya lo pusieron en una
cobijita verdad buñuelos
desde ahí ya sabía que algo no estaba
bien
y si cuando abrí el regalo me di cuenta
que era un suéter un simple suéter
naranja
y en ese momento yo ni siquiera sabía
que tenía entre mis manos la oportunidad
de cambiar mi vida para siempre
pero bueno el tiempo pasó el suéter se
quedó en el olvido y después de un rato
de estudiar diseño gráfico decidí
trabajar con mi papá en su agencia de
publicidad la verdad es que en esa en
esa etapa estábamos pues más o menos mal
mis papás se estaban separando mi
hermana estaba estudiando muy lejos así
que la idea era la siguiente iba a
trabajar y lo que ahorrará lo íbamos a
utilizar para que yo me fuera a la
universidad que yo quisiera siempre y
cuando no fuera en el extranjero dije ok
bajo todo iba muy bien en el arreglo
empiezo a trabajar a ganar dinero y de
pronto pues ya saben cómo son los chavos
dije mira ya tengo dinero voy a empezar
a gastarlo en viajes viajes en combi es
que mis amigos vivían del otro lado de
la ciudad pero pasa el lapso de tiempo
hablo con mi papá le digo papá creo que
en este tiempo he madurado bastante
ya lo decidí no voy a estudiar voy a
comprarme un xbox
una moto y voy a seguir trabajando
contigo y mi papá me dijo mira si haces
eso te quito todo tu dinero y deja
triste la broma sólo quería ver tu cara
sí sí sí te sorprendiste verdad y ahí me
tienen una semana después buscando
exámenes de admisión para poder entrar
en alguna universidad no sabía que iba a
estudiar así que el mismo día que fui al
examen lo decidí y estudie publicidad
para no hacerles el cuento largo fue por
esto mi papá tener una agencia de
publicidad yo estudio publicidad regresa
al negocio familiar listo pan comido y
pues estaba bastante equivocado durante
mi primer año de universidad
lage se me quebró mi mamá tenía una
fábrica de velas pero también estaba muy
mal la verdad no teníamos dinero para
nada
y el colmo fue que tampoco me dieron una
beca porque tenía muchos focos en mi
casa o sea estaba rentado pero hay
muchos focos de mi casa literalmente me
lo imagino así o sea si joven ya vimos
su estudio socioeconómico sus papás no
tienen propiedades están separados pero
siguen compartiendo un sur de hace 13
años
pero tiene muchos focos en su casa el
joven -cuya herradores no es no
la verdad
me imagino que la situación fue
muchísimo más complicada de lo que de lo
que yo recuerdo y estoy seguro que mis
papás dejaron de comer en tres ocasiones
para darme al menos doscientos pesos
cada dos semanas
dunn durante esa época tuve personas
increíbles a mi lado gente que se
entregó al 100% que me dieron su corazón
que me abrieron las puertas de su casa
para que yo fuera a comer con ellos o
incluso en la cafetería de la
universidad el pan era gratis entonces
bueno si vamos turnando para agarrar el
pan también los jugos eran gratis no si
vamos turnando para ir por el jugo
y en realidad no sabía a dónde quería ir
pero sabía donde no quería estar no
quería estar en un punto en donde
tuviera que pedirle prórroga al casero
para otro mes de renta sin pagar o que
tenía que abandonar el salón porque no
tenía derecho a presentar examen porque
no había pagado la colegiatura quería
dormir tranquilo quería poder devolverle
algo a la gente que me estaba apoyando a
la gente que yo quería
obviamente por la situación me metí a
trabajar y mi primer trabajo fue con con
un tío de un amigo que tenía una empresa
de banquetes entonces yo me encargaba de
todo lo que tenía que ser botanas
cacahuetes papas a cuánto la bolsa 10 la
ganancia pero después de eso me según
trabajo fue en una pequeña agencia de
publicidad especializada curiosamente en
redes sociales y al mismo tiempo empecé
a trabajar haciendo vídeos de
quinceañeras ya no me ponía el vestido
más bien me grababa los a los amigos de
las quinceañeras estos vídeos que
proyectan en las fiestas de amiga te
queremos mucho y la quinceañera llora
esos
toda mi vida me ha gustado hacer reír a
la gente porque creo que el reír es el
estado más puro de las personas pero eso
y estar desnudo pero eso es incómodo y
de hecho tuve muchos problemas en la
escuela por lo mismo o sea no por
desahogarme sino por echar relajo y
créanme que si yo hubiera tenido un
alumno como yo
a más pero afortunadamente me tocaron
buenos maestros porque no hubiera estado
cool retraer esa parte de mí
empecé en radio cuando tenía 6 años a
grabar algunos comerciales y en la prepa
grabábamos con mis amigos pues algunos
vídeos
ya sea imitando a algunos maestros
imitando a los compañeros o recreando
vídeos musicales o incluso haciendo
escenas de james bond todo de bajo
presupuesto o sea no teníamos a daniel
craig pero teníamos a daniel cruz
siempre fue
mi idea poder hacer cosas crear
contenido me encantaba pero nunca había
tenido la oportunidad de hacerlo en
grande
en mi familia está prohibido decir
groserías porque de acuerdo a mi papá es
una falta de respeto hacia las mujeres
del lado de mi mamá pues no tanto ellos
de veracruz
entonces ya se imaginarán el florido
vocabulario de mis días fue un choque
interesante pero fue por esta razón que
había muchos vídeos que a mí me gustaban
que quería compartir con con mi familia
y no podía porque decían groserías o
había doble sentido o algún albur
entonces yo no le veo nada de malo pero
siempre fue un impedimento el poder
compartirlo entonces fue fue ahí cuando
decidí hacer vídeos para todos vídeos
con un humor blanco que pudieras
compartir con tu primo de cuatro años o
con tu abuelita de 90 estamos en una
época en donde nos aislamos con las
redes sociales como diría mi mamá que si
el facebook el chat
instagram ya no tienes tiempo para mí
pero el simple hecho de crear un vídeo y
compartir un momento de tu día y hacer
reír juntos a la familia para mí eso era
algo importante por eso mis vídeos
tienen contenido pues bastante familiar
ya sea al primo que te pide los juegos
en su celular o la mamá que te regaña
porque no sacaste la ropa de la
acabadora y alguna horita la lavadora
pero bueno también está el estudiante
que nunca llegaba con las cosas de la
tarea
creo que el hecho de identificarte al
100% con lo que haces es clave para
poder decirle al mundo lo que quieres
después de de trabajar de hacer vídeos
de quinceañera decidí o sea no yo pero
ya les expliqué decidí hacer vídeos en
youtube y al principio fue muy
complicado porque me pegaban mucho los
comentarios negativos o sea nadie me
veía había 6 comentarios 5 eran
negativos que estás muy feo te tiran de
chiquito ojalá tú siempre sean
cancerígenos
y me pegó mucho tanto que deje de hacer
vídeos dos años hasta que llegue una
aplicación no sé si la recuerden que se
llamaban básicamente en una app en donde
subían vídeos de 6 segundos 6 segundos
muy poco para mí era más que suficiente
con el trabajo con la escuela seis
segundos era lo único que necesitaba
empiezo a hacer estos vídeos y no tenía
pelucas entonces empiezo a utilizar
suéteres como pues como si fuera mi
cabello en una ocasión todos mis
suéteres estaban sucios o sea todos
prestaban sucios
y había uno ahí guardado que había
estado conmigo los últimos seis años de
mi vida y que yo había olvidado
el suéter naranja que recibí esa navidad
lo vi y hasta donde dije no sé si usarlo
ahorita
o mejor me espero a los otros suéteres
en esos 10 segundos de duda tome la
mejor decisión de mi vida que fue
utilizar ese suéter
ese fue el primer vídeo
que llegó a 30 millones de
reproducciones en diferentes páginas yo
estaba acostumbrado a 800 reproducciones
700 de mi mamá 100 mías 30 millones de
reproducciones no podía creerlo
tanto fue que dije no esto no puede ser
una casualidad tenemos que hacer la
misma fórmula entonces me puse el suéter
grabamos y no sólo fue uno fueron 15
vídeos más que sobrepasaron las 20
millones de reproducciones en diferentes
páginas a partir de ahí las
oportunidades se fueron dando empecé a
trabajar con marcas empecé a conocer
lugares empecé a viajar conocí el mar en
7 ya lo conocía pero iba bien pero lo
más importante es que
y empecé a apoyar a mis papás en lo que
yo podía y además empecé a vivir de lo
que a mí me gustaba que era hacer vídeos
de comedia
tal vez muchos de ustedes se pregunten
por qué se llama un golpe de suéter tal
vez fue error de dedo ya lo dejaron así
no señores no es un error de dedo la
verdad es que ese suéter guardado y
olvidado probablemente menospreciado
durante seis años porque cuando yo lo
recibí no era lo que yo quería sin saber
que era lo que necesitaba ese suéter
cambió mi vida por completo y tal vez
ustedes me digan bueno sí pero eso no le
pasa a cualquier eso en realidad es un
golpe de suerte si bien dicen que la
suerte es es cuando la preparación se
encuentra con la oportunidad y para mí
fue un suéter pero dependió de mi
convertir este suéter
en mi vida en mi trabajo en mi empresa
en este caso varias
gracias agua tropa afortunadamente
salieron muchas oportunidades
actualmente soy socio de una empresa de
marketing digital la número uno en
puebla
una empresa de que está empezando que es
de limpieza
una agencia de medios digitales una
pequeña televisora y otras cosillas que
ya les contaré pero todo para mí empezó
con un suéter que yo menosprecie porque
no era lo que yo esperaba
cuántas veces no hemos visto las
oportunidades que se nos presentan
simplemente porque no es lo que
queríamos esperábamos cuántas veces no
apreciamos o le damos el valor real a
las personas las situaciones a las cosas
que nos rodean cuántas veces no vemos
las puertas que se abren frente a
nosotros
si yo hubiera recibido ese xbox
probablemente hubiera jugado 34 años y
ya nada más no hubiera construido un
futuro o una carrera gracias a ese
simple suéter puedo decir con orgullo
que estoy aquí platicando frente a
ustedes
amigos yo creo que un simple buenos días
puede ser la oportunidad perfecta para
cambiar tu vida o la de alguien más y no
les estoy diciendo que va a cambiar de
la noche a la mañana y tampoco que estén
pensando en las oportunidades que no
vieron o en las oportunidades que vienen
no simplemente les digo que después de
diez años de dedicarme a hacer vídeos y
seis viviendo de esto y que gracias a
esto salieron otras oportunidades que a
veces con el simple hecho de observar lo
que nos rodea
de sentir el momento de ser pacientes de
aprovechar las herramientas que tenemos
y de no dudar tanto de nosotros mismos
las oportunidades las oportunidades
llegan porque son sabias y esperan el
momento adecuado y cuando llegan lo van
a sentir porque llegan como un golpe
como un golpe de suéter muchas gracias